This is the last of the word
problems that Kortaggio had
sent, and they're all
interesting because they're
all involving distances
and rates and times.
They all involve you having to
do a little bit of implicit
algebra without having to
explicitly solve for values of
variables, and that's
why they're fun.
So this one says Ann and
Betty, two cyclists,
start simultaneously.
Ann at point A and
Betty at point B.
They travel to each other
at constant speeds.
So let's say that Ann is
traveling with velocity A
and Betty is traveling
with velocity B.
Constant speeds.
They pass each other
in 30 minutes.
OK, so they're going to
pass each other someplace
in between A and B.
I'll just arbitrarily
draw that.
They're going to pass
each other there.
And what are these distances?
It took them 30 minutes to both
to get this point, right?
They pass each other
in 30 minutes.
And Ann, headed from point
B, arrives there in
another 20 minutes.
OK, so this distance
takes Ann 30 minutes.
So what is the actual distance?
Well, it's always useful to
write distance is equal
to rate times time.
So what's the actual
distance she traveled?
Well, the rate is va.
She traveled a rate of va and
her time -- they tell us -- it
took her 30 minutes
to get there.
So va times 30.
Let's say this velocity
is expressed in minutes.
Fair enough.
And then Ann, headed for
point B, arrives there
in another 20 minutes.
So this is going to take
her another 20 minutes.
So this distance
right here is what?
She's going at the
same velocity, but it
takes her 20 minutes.
So the distance is
velocity times time.
So it's va times 20, 20va.
Fair enough.
How many minutes after Ann
arrives at point B will
Betty arrive at point A?
So Betty was going in this
direction, they meet right
here, and then she keeps
going and hits point A.
So the key realization here is
that this took Ann 30 minutes
to get here, but it also took
Betty 30 minutes to get here.
So what's this distance in
terms of Betty's velocity?
What's this distance?
Well, distance is equal
to rate times time.
It took Betty 30 minutes
to go this distance
at a velocity of vb.
So it took her 30vb meters,
or whatever, actually.
We don't even have to
specify the units.
Whatever the units
the velocity is in.
If it's in meters per
minute, then this is
the distance in meters.
This distance is 30vb.
Right?
So essentially, we just have to
figure out how long it takes
her to travel this remaining
distance and we would
have solved the problem.
So how can we do that?
Well, we can already set
up a relationship between
vb and va, because this
distance is the same.
It doesn't matter how
fast you travel it, the
distance doesn't change.
So we know that 30 times
Betty's velocity is equal to 20
times Ann's velocity, 20va.
And so if we wanted to express
Ann's velocity in terms of
Betty's velocity -- let's just
do it that way -- if we divide
both sides by 20 we get 3/2 of
Betty's velocity is equal
to Ann's velocity.
Fair enough.
So what is this distance in
terms of Betty's velocity?
We know it in terms
of Ann's velocity.
In terms of Ann's velocity,
it's 30 times Ann's velocity.
Right?
So what is 30 times Ann's
velocity in terms of
Betty's velocity?
Well, if we multiply this times
30, that's 30 times Ann's
velocity, so we can multiply
both sides of this times 30.
So if you multiply 30 times
here and times thirty,
this is the distance.
This distance right here.
Ann's velocity
times 30 minutes.
It took her 30 minutes
to travel that far.
So this is the same distance
expressed in Betty's velocity.
So 30 times 3 is 90
divided by 2 is 45.
So it's 45vb.
So this distance
up here is 45vb.
So distance is equal to
rate times -- so this
is rate -- times time.
So this is how many
minutes it took Betty to
travel this distance.
So what is the
question asking us?
How many minutes after
Ann reaches point B will
Betty arrive at point A.
So they both reach right here.
In another 20 minutes,
Ann gets here.
And in another 45 minutes,
Betty will get over there.
Another 45 minutes.
So it takes Ann 20
minutes to get here.
It takes Betty 45 minutes to
get here, after their meeting
right at the center.
So it's going to take
Betty another 25 minutes.
Right?
After 20 minutes Ann is here
and then we have to wait
another 25 minutes for Betty
to get here, 45 minutes
after this meeting.
So the answer is 25 minutes.
How many minutes after Ann
arrives at point B will
Betty arrive at point A.
Yes, 25 minutes.
They could have just asked how
many minutes after the meeting
will it take Betty
to reach point A.
It would have been 45.
But they want to know
how many more minutes
after Ann gets there.
Anyway, I thought you would
find that useful and, a final
time, thanks to Kortaggio
for sending that problem.